[Music]
being in a shipyard in general sucks
without any of the coved stuff
madeleine walchko works on an american
container ship that got stuck in the
shanghai shipyard during the city's
covid lockdown and she documented her
two months-long experience once the
lockdown happened it was just kind of
one thing after the next
she and the crew had to rely on local
authorities for supplies we have a
delivery here of food and water took
regular cova tests
all while living on a semi-dismantle
ship the rainforest is back
we're just trying to keep busy just to
stay sane their struggle shows just how
hard it was for shipyards as well as
companies in the region to keep working
through shanghai's covid restrictions
[Music]
in february the president wilson docked
at a shipyard just north of the city's
port for repairs that were originally
meant to take a little over a month this
ship works 24 7. we don't stop weltchko
is the ship's second officer and is from
washington state she gave the wall
street journal permission to use her
footage
the plan was to finish the maintenance
then pick up containers at the port
watchko says when the work started some
days about 500 shipyard workers would
come aboard but about a month into their
stay shanghai entered a lockdown watchko
says the workers stopped coming and most
of the repair work ground to a halt
we're current kind of already used to
being on board the difference being that
we're not moving there's no work
progressing
restricted to the ship by local
authorities the crew was stuck on a
vessel that was midway through repairs
starting to get flooded already in here
unable to stock up on their regular food
supplies they relied on government
deliveries at the beginning of the
lockdown we had about a month meet left
it was
a little um terrifying the crew also had
to undergo regular covet testing
following a schedule set by the shipyard
authorities
the pcr test will be done on the 1st 2nd
4th 7th 10th 14th 17th and 21st days
watchko says all of this took a toll on
the mental health of the crew
it's difficult when there's no
set date you know no set plan
everyone's up and down all the time
the company cma cgm group which owns the
president wilson said they were in daily
contact with the crew to ensure their
health and safety and worked with local
authorities to organize food and other
necessities
about a month after things came to a
halt the shipyard implemented a system
that would allow workers to return to
the vessel despite the city's coveted
restrictions it's called a closed loop
basically the workers are locked down in
a confined area
and they're not allowed to leave
but they can still work
this close-off environment wasn't only
used at the shipyard but it's also been
implemented by factories and financial
companies where employees lived and
slept at work
some even setting up tents for privacy
it's a way for officials to balance two
competing goals curb the spread of covet
and keep production going to limit
economic damage and global supply chain
fallout
companies like tesla and china's largest
state-owned automaker saic all
implemented closed loops during
shanghai's lockdown
but this system isn't always running at
100 capacity compared to normal times
closed loop does not mean perfect it
doesn't mean perfect loop jared ward is
the chairman of the supply chain
committee at the american chamber of
commerce in shanghai he also works for
houston logistics a company that
organizes and manages the transport of
goods at the port for suppliers and
retailers you're basically concentrating
the labor without allowing them to go
home i mean there's a human toll to that
as well as just the general lack of
efficiency of having
enough people
many of the city shipyards also face
reduced capacity according to the
president wilson's crew only a fraction
of the original workforce returned to
the ship when work resumed it was just a
trickle like it was 10 people and then
it was 20 people and then it was 50 to
60 people along with fewer people there
were not enough materials coming into
shipyards in shanghai for repairs that's
because the lockdown created a logistics
headache truck drivers coming into the
city had to take covetus or quarantine
slowing down deliveries to factories and
the port even though you may have the
closest labor on site you still don't
have your components flowing into the
manufacturing site so with fewer people
and materials the ship's repairs dragged
on for months and the president wilson's
crew simply had to wait
we're never going to get out of here
the port of shanghai and the company
that owns a shipyard costco shipping
heavy industry didn't respond to
requests for comment the city's
government lifted covert restrictions on
june 1st and about a week later
the president wilson completed its
repairs and set out to pick up cargo at
the port we are finally on our way down
the yangtze river
but there's still uncertainty for
companies that rely on shipping and
manufacturing in the region biggest
concern is you know this coped situation
we went through in shanghai you know
easily could come back next month or you
know could come back in another location
and you know how is your supply chain
designed is it flexible enough to
actually deal with that
shipping analysts say as trucking and
activity at the port return to normal
they expect the resumption of export
shipments to have a ripple effect
creating congestion at other major ports
around the world especially as the back
to school and holiday shopping seasons
start to kick in companies operating in
china could become increasingly wary of
more disruptions caused by strickkovich
strategies that's why we see people
deciding about alternative supply points
whether they're still inside of china or
outside so this is where the impact will
be felt for i think many
certainly months but many years to come
the president wilson is finding its way
back into the global supply chain with
its final destination at the us's
busiest container poor complex at los
angeles and long beach
people don't really think about the
humans involved and that we have limits
just go go go all the time think about
the cargo and think about the money and
think about the ship when you're already
fatigued sleep deprived it's
excruciating at times
you